alright Velma we've got another thing to
get onto here very quickly shifting from
the world of PlayStation to the world of
Microsoft and they announced a couple
days ago that I guess why you would
cross-platform multiplayer I guess is
the best way to play yeah to describe it
xbox one games playing not only with
Windows 10 games which is not all that
new in the world of video game
multiplayer but also opening the doors
for Xbox games to play with PlayStation
games and wolves as i was about psionic
sub s a cig noses run video game company
Sonic's have come out and said that this
is great that they're going to try and
implement this the rocket league which
is great because already that was a
PlayStation 4 game that could play we
repeat with the pc fan base and vice
versa and the xbox one guys were sort of
left on their own and where do you think
this comes from like the in i guess the
reasoning behind microsoft doing this is
this just another shaking off more you
know leftovers from the previous regime
or does this actually work for games
like the division for instance where
there are people about to buy this game
and maybe the install base is lower on
the xbox one and they want they don't
want to discourage people from playing
on that i think in terms of software
sales it's not gonna hurt anyone you
know you have games like titanfall where
people are really liking it or evolved
which is you know i think was a good
game but then the multiplayer bass drops
off really fast so now you know ideally
you'll have three different platforms to
just really bolster multiplayer base and
i can only imagine it's gonna help the
developers making games it's gonna help
you know the players like never like
have a shortage you know cuz multiplayer
basis but no people realize just really
hard to maintain like not many games
keep one for longer than a few weeks
after launch a huge one and i can only
imagine this will help from a business
standpoint I i think it's i don't know
like the actual like how the numbers of
shake out i think it's a good move on
place sony's parts like in sorry
microsoft's parts like invite sony into
this cuz you know like you said with
games like rocket league it works really
well if they could just figure it out
like how to do it across three different
platforms and the best case scenario i
think it's a good move yeah i mean it
makes business sense right more than
anything else yeah i think so i mean
it's definitely going to open up more
or just a bigger install base as you
said right so that more people can play
with other people you know it's like a
dream right like I want to play with my
friend and destiny or something that
plays on xbox one that I can't do
because we're on set for consoles and we
don't want to re-level character to play
with each other because that's just a
huge waste of time how many times have
you bought a game on a specific platform
because of your mates like I figured I'd
do that all the time yeah like the
division was when I was like I want to
get it on pc but everyone's playing it
on PlayStation 4 and then I was like
I'll just buy it on pc iguess and rocket
League is not a perfect example of this
where you know the xbox one version
obviously has a bunch of cool cars that
aren't on the other ones and maybe Halo
fans want to play it up but then they're
like um well maybe I'll just get it on
PlayStation because all my buddies are
playing on that or PC and that seems
like to me kind of the hardest part of
this from a business perspective in
terms of so there's a lot of this
exclusivity now right or like one month
early access to you know content right
how do you open this up for like I mean
obviously it's not all the games right
away in a perfect world yes I but how do
you do something where you know like
let's say the division is getting Xbox
one DLC first right like how does does
the PlayStation people just not they're
not able to play with the xbox one
people in that content only then or like
the Destiny had guns that you know and
on ps4 that xbox one didn't have so like
oh that guy's got a hawk moon and we
don't even have that yeah in our game I
mean I wonder yeah because like because
then presumably the playstation 4
version of rocket League would need to
have the Warthog in ish to display the
Warthog cuz like even if you can't buy
yer so yeah I'd see the Batman car even
though I've not bought that dlc pack but
you know cuz then you're into like weird
licensing issues we're ok now Microsoft
gonna license had the look of the
Warthog on a sony console ya know where
that problem wasn't there before so yeah
I wonder I mean I mean it's opened the
door whether or not you know people take
advantage of us one to see and master
the hero in the three shots at end of
the console war uh if anything dislike
shows that because of words alive and
well Microsoft's are like Ben again
right I think the console wars will go
on definitely like indefinitely as long
as there are like console specific games
joke right like it's like oh yeah I
because from their perspective it's like
oh yeah I got ps4 and I have this game
and you don't that's why ps4 is superior
because it also looks better anyway but
you know what i mean like Wars alive
because of you Eric Ted I know that's
what I'm there I'll unborn yeah the
console wars LOL i don't jump on because
of a tomb raider just a little bit me
corte you know Andy Bauman's not here
anymore we don't stalk about forward to
shout out to my man bow and it's gonna
crash to the wall he's on to talk about
40 yeah he works for you that's why the
division now no no no company man now he
talks about uh that's the the crew Oh
driving game on the bandwagon oh wow
okay night there you go yeah I guess
cross-platform open at the last point on
this psionic said we're thrilled to
confirm the rocket League will be one of
the first games to take advantage of
this new capability by enabling
cross-network players what they're
calling us between xbox one and pc
players been an open invitation for
other networks to participate as well
sorry that was sony who said that an
open invitation to android/ios under
sony as well i guess so yeah there you
go i let us know if you're excited about
this in the comments as well in the
twitch chat do you have a situation is
there like one game where you and your
buddies play that you wish you had
cross-platform play across the network
play that maybe this will open up let us
know in the comments below
you